pennsylvanie et remplissez-la de votre lumière
avec jésus-christ nous demandons
nous demandons le calme priez pour notre presse et
nous prions cela en votre doux nom amen
amen
je ne l'accepte pas et président
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit certifié
ne me laisse pas dire ceci  si nous le pouvons si
nous d'abord, comme vous le savez,
nous avions des observateurs démocrates et des sondages qui
surveillaient
chaque scrutin lors de nos élections ici dans
le comté à chaque scrutin,
mais nous n'étions pas autorisés à le faire à
Philadelphie en tant que républicains, il a 70
millions de personnes qui ont  nous revenons
et nous ne voulons pas de discours de concession
jusqu'à ce que nous sachions que
chaque vote légal a été compté et que nous nous sentons
bien à ce sujet et qu'il n'y a pas de corruption
et s'il y a de la corruption, les gens
doivent aller en prison et que m.
biden soit clair sur votre relation avec  le
parti communiste chinois
ne croit toujours pas qu'il a gagné
jusqu'à ce qu'ils
fassent peut-être un recomptage dont
ils doivent d'abord s'occuper,
mais j'étais contrarié j'étais contrarié il n'est pas mon
gars donald trump est mon gars
c'est ce que c'est  est-ce  voici rien d'autre que
nous pourrons faire s'il
intente des poursuites et qu'ils trouvent que
tout était légal,
alors vous n'avez qu'à laisser tomber je veux dire
c'est ce que vous devez faire juste laisser
tomber
honnêtement je ne sais pas s'il y a un  beaucoup de choses que
joe biden peut faire
pour unifier le pays je pense que c'est
au pays lui-même je pense que c'est
au peuple américain que
nous devons arrêter de regarder les
différences les uns des autres et essayer de trouver un
terrain d'entente vous savez à la fin aujourd'hui nous '  re
tous les américains nous devons commencer à agir
comme ça